bismillah al hamdulillah assalamu
alaikum peace be unto you today we're
going to be talking with our teacher our
ship who's here to help us understand
Islam the way of all the prophets that
way of submission and surrender not to
your desires not to a man not to one
mode the one who created man and woman
the creator of the heavens and earth
we're going to be trying to distinguish
Islam from back home cultures it's kind
of got intertwined you got some things
some confusion so we want to make sure
that we have the blueprint because we
want to do things right we want to do
things according to how the crater wants
us to do things we don't want to follow
our desires and get even more confused
so to help unravel the confusion when we
come back shake tofique chaudhary here
on the danger will be right back love
there's only one helmet is his messenger
of love
ha there's only one bed and Jesus was
his messenger know why I did that maybe
it maybe it's just to break the ice
assalamu alaikum share coastal Anthony
how are you how are you very good thank
you thank you very much for being with
us that's great no problem have you been
very good thank you I'm very excited
that you're back with us here on the
Dean show I'm sure look very busy
traveling educating the people
attractively thank you is that a
litigated your life to this beautiful
way of life Islam well lollie you know
I'm actually endeavoured in debited to a
la strada to my family's to my parents
were actually being able to do it no and
you were last time as we spoke you were
also pursuing your doctorate degree
Zachary yeah in medicine yes so I can
call you dr. children out I prefer you
not to just call me brother that's right
okay so look like my shake our teacher
tell us now we need to understand a
little better because people know that
Islam is that way of life the way of
life of all the messengers that way of
submitting yourself entirely to the
crater that happens in earth this but
now we have some things that are
cultural practices so there might be
some confusion to some of the lay people
because now there are some things that
might have developed over the years and
have gotten mixed up with Islam so we
want to talk about a basic blueprint so
we don't get to mixing things up like a
buffet so what is culture and what is
accepted with the normal cultures of
society and what is clear Islam and what
can mix and what cat makes let's talk
about this for a second right it's I
think a really really good question
because unfortunately what's happened
these days is that people have obviously
been born into Muslim families and
because of the the ultimate the total
lack of Islamic education and the fact
that people don't even know the basics
of the religion
sometimes if people have forgotten the
the difference between what is culture
and what is Islam so we find for example
in Muslim countries these days people
pray not because they really want to
pray or because it's in the heart to
pray but really it's because its culture
you know it's time to pray that our
dance coming you know what do people
generally do they just go to the mosque
impress we might as well do that yeah
for people for example wear the hijab
not because it's a it's at the actually
doing it because do they really want to
protect themselves from others or to all
to really be covered for the sake o
Allah span or Thailand yeah but they're
doing it simply because it's part of the
culture and hijab has just become a
convenient way of dressing to to cover
up your you know yourself and so in
reality we need to break that barrier
and to break that barrier a lot of
education needs to happen a lot of that
one needs to happen to people who do
know the truth need to go out and
actually say that to people and a lot of
a clarity needs to come into the whole
picture of exactly what basic amount of
knowledge needs to be there in the minds
of people so that you can break the
difference so that really depends upon
the society that we're talking about we
know that in Islam a certain amount of
basic knowledge is obligatory upon every
single person so what is that basic
amount of knowledge that is obligatory
and every person well we know that we
need to know the basics of our belief we
need to know the basics of our actions
things that we need to do we need to
know the basics of any action that the
community or the people do that that
they involved in like for example before
they do business they need to know what
the ruins of business before the deal in
marriage and divorce on the rulings of
marriage and divorce yeah so ultimately
every believer is required to know a
certain set basic amount of belief
knowledge in a certain basic amount of
knowledge in belief and a certain basic
mount knowledge in action and when this
is clear in people's minds then the
delineation between what is religion
what is culture will become far more
clearer because the problem is happening
in that the most basic things people are
mixing up with their culture so we know
for example these days
a you know female circumcision is it let
me give you that example here female
circumcision which is practiced in the
African countries in a way in which the
whole clitoris and the whole female
genital external genitals actually
removed this is something which is
totally against the principles of Islam
because the goal they say is to not let
women have excessive desire right that's
the understanding that is usually given
yeah although in Islam there is no basis
for total removal of the tour of the
genitalia at all there is something
culture that is cultural that is a
practice an African practice that has
come into Islam yeah but become into
Muslims and the practice right the same
way like for example you might say in
India the example is that in India we
know the Hindus when they's to marry
their daughters off they had to give
money to the husbands where is it is
lance other around in Islam the the men
have to give a dowry or a marriage gift
to the to the women it's not the
absolute opposite not that is it and I
know for example even my own parents and
they're Muslims right yeah and when they
got married it was almost like my
parents my mom had to give a gift to my
dad and although my dad didn't accept it
but the point was it was almost expected
as a cultural practice and we have many
many similar cultural practices in many
things where there'd be times of death
times of marriage times of divorce times
of you know prayer and worship you know
would there be in our in our Hajj and
Umrah we have so many things which
actually cultural practices that we need
to be rooted out and the best way to do
that is through education now we put a
little flavoring in our coffee get a
latte put little caramel if your steak
needs a little bit of salt you know to
amplify the taste what about with our
way of life this religion or you you
want to sweeten up you know your tea put
some extra sugar let's but if someone
argue and said you know we're just
trying to add some flavor here we're
just trying to you know spice things up
yeah you know what there are two
problems you the first problem is that
you
believe that Islam is actually deficient
or the taste is actually not good enough
for you you actually need to sweeten it
up or something like that right that's
actually claiming that the religion is
deficient would you agree that's
actually claiming that the religion
needs a version 2 or that we need to
improve certain things about the
religion which is not just to our taste
or some here that would be claiming that
the Provost did not give his message to
us but the Quran is not complete that
Allah Subhan Allah did not complete the
religion and that would be a tremendous
tremendous thing to say would you agree
yeah this is why innovation something
that is new into the religion is so
disliked in our in our Dean because not
that we don't really want to want to do
good for the religion what we're saying
is is that by actually adding something
you're actually claiming something else
you claiming that it's deficient you're
claiming that that just like the food is
need salt so the religion need need
something else and you have the audacity
to say that you think the religion is
not complete okay that's the first
problem the second problem is that you
you're claiming that the religion
doesn't have the sweetness or the
religion doesn't have the joy that
you're looking for and that's that's to
say that that Islam you know is we hear
this sometimes people say that you know
religion is all boring you know it's not
all excellence you know and we want some
fun in it and this is no fun in islam
what the reality is you know what you
haven't approached islam in the right
way you've looked at the slab as a set
of rigid laws and guidelines you haven't
looked beyond that you haven't looked at
the beauty of thinking about Allah even
thought about the sweetness of basking
in the love of Allah you even thought
about like for example i remember my
share was he was asked a question by a
man and a man was a chef I've been
trying to get married yes and you know I
can't get married and and I'm having
this this tremendous difficulty and he
gave a talk that till now I remember and
he spoke about how a person whose heart
is in growths in the remeron svala finds
no need for physical pleasures Yeah
right and but a la nena someone whose
heart isn't in total bliss thinking
about Allah the day that he will meet
him the day the day in which he will
speak to him alone
and he is standing sitting and lying
thinking about God and the creation of
the heavens of the earth the one who
Ponder's about the day the first night
in the grave don't think what the second
man the grave just the first time the
grave the one upon his about it well lie
he is filled with a different sort of
thought in his mind a different sort of
attention span and he had officious of
outlook towards his life and he is he
doesn't waste his time looking for
distractions because these things are
sometimes mere mere distractions we're
not saying that instead there's an
enjoyment by the way we're saying that
there is tremendous in John Muir the
prophecy salaam would would have
competitions with his wives he would
joke around with his wives in one of the
narrations we hear that the prophets
assalaam was sitting with one of his
legs and one in the house of one of his
wives another leg and the house another
wife and and then I should all do lon
has she cooked a nice meal of something
called ferried was which is meat cooked
with bread in a curry yep and she
brought that to Row solar system and the
prophets Ursula ate a little bit and
then he offered it to Sofia or the Alana
was the other wife auto solar system and
Sofia said I'm sorry I've already eaten
and so I should said no you're
definitely going to eat and she said no
I'm sorry I'm eaten and so I should took
the food like this a little bit of food
and the she threw it at sofia and landed
on a nose uh-huh and it's true it's an
authentic hadith by the way and so what
did you promise him did and he also took
some food and he threw that I have a fun
there's having fun now they don't have a
Bigfoot food fight yeah what we're
saying is this harmless run they're
harmless fun yep yes so tell us now okay
you know we see other favs they do
things to bring the people in so if the
moistures are empty and you got some
people wanting to be creative maybe we
can bring a band in the masjid what
about this things like of this nature
yeah you know there are certain things
in a slab I mean there's a difference
between innovation and public good yeah
so we know that when the prophets Ursula
passed away and put ad was in different
parts in different areas look what I
wasn't collected in one go so the person
can say hey the people put the Quran
into one into one piece and they were
all different part
why is that allowed and why can't I try
and do something which would be for the
public which would bring more good to
people just like I said bring more
people back into the muscle you know
start all these competitions and all
these other things so you're talking
about could you see it you know you go
one church is competing with the neck so
absolutely brings a rap band the other
1i second pop band and then it's a
competition absolutely they're filling
them up somehow to keep the memberships
coming in so Muslims see this is it
maybe they say we get some good night
absolutely so what we're saying is is
that there's no problem with helping
Islam but as long as it is as it is
within the realms of the guidelines
Whistler now we know that for example of
course bands and music and dancing in
free mixing etc this is not something
condoned by slam yeah but the point is
what if someone said okay let's just not
do something openly Haram but what about
doing something openly Helen like for
example like a prophets birthday for
example yeah let's celebrate the
prophets birthday even though the
prophecy didn't do that do so and people
would justify that but by saying that
hey this is increasing the love for a
solar system but we try and we look at
it objectively we say hey there's a
difference between public good and
innovation in something that is done for
the public good it is first of all
condoned by Islam okay second of all a
public good is something which does not
increase the hardship upon us if
anything he decreases hardship upon us
thirdly the public good is something
that it that conforms to the goals and
principles of the Sharia on the other
hand and innovation is something which
increases hardship upon us and an
innovation the reason for its existence
already would have existed in the time
or a solar system of the prophecy didn't
do so so therefore for us to claim that
we need to do something else to do more
right would be an innovation because
they cause for its existence already
existed at the time Rosa yeah so for
example we could say you know the need
for mankind to love rosula also existed
far more the time Rasulullah saw Salem
so why should we now celebrate the
prophecies on birthday when the possum
didn't do so at that yarn even with the
need existed at that time do you honest
what I'm sayin so therefore that the
point is more friend
that we can try and and use 101 ideas to
increase you know membership or Islam we
can use 101 different ways of strategies
to bring people back into the Dean as
long as number one it doesn't go against
our principles yeah and our values and
number two number two as long as it's
not real clear innovation the anything
so now just so the viewers will
understand what we're saying here is
that knowledge is key so whatever is in
the blueprint this is what we follow and
no one can bring something in that's not
sanctioned by the crater and his last
and final messenger prophet muhammad
peace be upon us absolutely because you
know one of the things that that that's
really important to understand is that
if if a religion doesn't have any firm
principles and basis and values it's not
a religion at all you see the problem
with christianity these days is that
they're redefining the values straight
away they are redefining the principles
here what we're saying is no Islam has
set values and set principles and set
guidelines and then everything else can
can can therefore be looked into about
in adding adding certain certain
strategies in order to bring people in
as long as the values all right some of
the principles are there as long as
these things are clear and set in stone
unison saying yeah so otherwise you have
no idea logic so it's okay now somebody
wants to invent a better way to
communicate through some kind of super
duty cell phone or someone wants to
invent a car that goes faster this is
okay absolutely this kind of technology
this kind of development innovation is
okay absolutely but in the matters of
this perfect way of life Islam the
religion me and you can't spice it up a
little bit we can't do anything that we
think now we're doing better than the
crater you know what if if there was you
know we could just follow what we wanted
to do there would be no need to set a
profit okay there'd be no need to give
us a book that would never change Yeah
right there'll be no need to give us a
snack or a chain of narration but which
we know that our our our statements or a
solar system are correct yeah the renown
follow this we could just invented what
we thought was right what we felt was
right what we knew was right okay so
we're starting to understand a little
better a few more points before we come
to it because this is a very important
issue because you can see as other
people of other faiths just to get the
congregation from leaving they'll do
juggling tricks magicians bands all
sorts of things and from one church to
the next or one place to the next
everything is different but in Islam is
the perfect way of life everything is
there you just have to follow some in
yeah you know the ends don't justify the
means yes LOM right the ends do not
justify the means that this is really
really important in Christianity and all
these other things we're seeing these
days sometimes I say hey the ends will
justify the means yeah and they don't
even fit what the values are they losing
out because it's the principle that the
overlooking because of this you know
Gary no these are values and principles
then set and set in stone it's not only
important to just get there it's
important how we get there as well
gotcha so some closing comments and
suggestions for those who sincerely want
to follow this way of life how it has
been ordained by the creator of the
heavens and earth and they don't want to
get into things that have been added my
man give some advice for that sincere
individual those individuals please I
think my sincere advice to those people
who really want to follow the fall of
the truth would be to realize that Islam
is evidence-based okay in medicine you
know when we practice medicine before we
come to a patient and we want to give
them the right medicine we don't just
say hey you know what it's great to just
giving them given any medic medicine but
rather we give them the medicine that is
evidence-based that is evidence behind
it with trial it on hundreds of patients
we know it to work vast majority of the
time ninety-five percent ninety-nine
percent of the time so we know this is
right for example so for example you
just have a common cold we're not going
to give you antibiotics because vast
majority of common cold sixty percent of
the time it's viruses right you're
honest what I'm saying here so in the
same way Islam is evidence-based the
profits Ursula kept on focusing on that
Allah says in the Quran in jail
can be a unit in amman or you believe if
a untrustworthy person comes to you with
information then verified we know in
Islam for example we don't just accept
any hadith any narration we accept a
hadith that is authentic because it has
a chain of narration back to those
little lot so what I'm saying is it's
lamb is about knowledge the first one
word revealed to us was someone's
apricot read the Quran comes from the
word Cara are to read so the and and the
greatest miracle of the prophecies and
was a book that is meant to be read yeah
so our Dean is about knowledge it's
about evidence-based and our practice is
evidence-based we don't just practice
anything we practice based on the
evidence of the Koran and from the
authentic sooner that has been proven
directly to be authentic and from the
profit system what can give us more
satisfaction than that knowing that we
are following something that's evidence
based in the same way when we help
patients we know it's evidence-based we
have we have certainty in our heart that
you know what we're doing the best thing
we can for the patient in the same way
we should be with the religion how can
you follow a book how can you follow a
ruling that we don't know the evidence
for right and this is my advice to
people whenever you do things do it
evidence-based thank you very much may
god almighty the Creator Allah reward
you accept it with Eddie pleasure's all
mine boy I hope you got to benefit I
surely did this is something that's very
simple if it's sanctioned by the creator
of the heavens and earth if there's a
basis for it the last and final
messenger sent to man kind of Prophet
Muhammad he explained it to us he taught
it to us and matters of deen religion
and we do it we submit to it otherwise
we don't need it and with that said
we'll see you next time here on the Dean
show I said I'm alaikum peace be unto
you mean a shape on yo G
bismillahi rahmani raheem wah wah wah
local mated joaquina hawa rajan I mean
hahaha while foraging I mean haha boom
salmon who you know wanna be a jam in la
piña moon wanna be wattage on a
phenomenal aroun Leopoldo me Tamara he
were my military ID him avinash moon
own so the logical aha me mad don't be
too long mima to be too long enough who
seemed warming
Marla moon why akula holiness l'homme in
one
I will pay the moon
own questions otagiri any Mustafa mwen
la la la' kaddipudi ruelas easy Lonnie
Qualcomm aeropuerto una who manage ela
hotter the corrosion in the pas de leche
am soo young bovina ha
dude aric Almirola losa be open
what we love FIFA luckiest bajo
the dvds for dour is allah has said in
the car honest with a now 16 125 will do
elasa be a little bigger bill hikmah to
invite all to the way of your lord with
wisdom beautiful preaching and reason
with them in ways that are best and this
is a great opportunity for you to take
up the obligation take up the call as
allah has told you to do and share this
beautiful message with the world islam
submission to the One God doesn't see
what everyone's talking about if you
find one contradiction it can't be from
God but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
for spring garden I would never give up
spending this message hope then you take
that necessary step you don't know if
you're gonna live till tomorrow so you
gotta find that urges you to do the
right thing right now if you say that
you're not believe in Jesus you have
stepped outside of his none you cannot
be a Muslim is that ended our faith to
its cold ain't lay everybody sleeping I
arise and ask a lot of thinking me Omar
you see hola you know all the sins I do
I turn to you to figure my scene
tomorrow I'm seen for slave
oh my lord I'm the one runs away oh the
guide me